I'm not going to comment on any details
relating to this specific case or the
individual are under consideration but
there has been clear work a foot with
the NCA and all Partners to try and
tackle the problem of illegal migration
I'm very encouraged by the relationship
that we have built with the French and
I'm grateful to the French authorities
for their real commitment and work on
tackling this problem but it's
absolutely clear that as I made clear in
my statement that on no occasion did I
block hotels or veto advice to procure
extra and emergency accommodation
actually this the the data and the facts
are that on my watch since the 6th of
September over 30 new hotels were agreed
which would provide over 4 500
additional Hotel bed spaces which will
be brought into use since the start of
October over 13 new hotels will provide
over 1800 additional Hotel bed spaces so
and also since the 6th of September 9
000 migrants have left manston uh many
of them heading towards Hotel
accommodation those are the facts I
encourage the right from the lady to
stick to the facts and not fantasy Madam
Deputy speaker however she raises some
other points and I would just like to
say this that my letter to the home
Affairs select committee sent today
addresses all of the matters that she
has just raised transparency and
comprehensively I've been clear that I
made an error of judgment I apologized
for that error I took responsibility for
it and I resigned
so Madame Deputy sneaker
does the house want to hear what the
Home Secretary has to say
Home Secretary
I apologize for the era I took
responsibility Madame Deputy speaker and
I resigned for the era
but let's be clear about what's really
going on here Madam speaker
the British people deserve to know which
party is serious about stopping the
invasion and
little post and which party is not some
40
000 people have arrived on the south
coast this year alone many of them
facilitated by criminal gangs some of
them actual members of criminal gangs so
let's stop pretending that they are all
refugees in distress the whole country
knows that that is not true and It's
Only The Honorable members opposite who
pretend otherwise Madam Deputy speaker
we need to be straight with the public
the system is broken illegal
migration
[Applause]
illegal migration is out of control and
too many people are more interested in
playing political parlor games
covering up the truth then solving the
problem
I Madam Deputy speaker I'm utterly
serious about ending the scourge of
illegal migration and I am determined to
do whatever it takes to break the
criminal gangs and fix our hopelessly
lacks Asylum system that Madam Deputy
speaker is why I am in government
and that is why there are some people
who would prefer to be rid of me
well
[Applause]
order
I should just point out that I can hear
who's making the noise and it'll be a
long time before they're called to ask
me questions it's such a mistake
Madame Deputy speaker let them try
I know that I speak for the decent law
abiding patriotic to charge
people from every background that wants
safe and secure borders labor is Running
Scared that this party might just
deliver them